there's been a lot of great westerns on
television that have had kind of a
hostage story there's a lot of Agatha
Christie in this story and it also feels
like you're taking a lot of the guest
stars or guest characters from every
Western and throwing them in the same
room yeah are you thinking about
character first you think about story
how do these people how do the eight
come together in your mind as opposed to
most other movies I was actually kind of
influenced by a lot of Western TV shows
that I've been watching in the last five
years like you know the bonanza and
Virginian in particularly but Big Valley
and Gunsmoke stuff like that and one of
the things that influenced me that led
me to this was I in particularly watch
the episodes that had really cool guest
stars in them like William Shatner or
Robert Culp or uh James Coburn or people
Vic Morrow people like that and one of
the things that I noticed is when I
watched those episodes if Robert Culp
was the guest star of The Virginian the
episode was about him
it wasn't about Doug McClure wasn't
about James jury he had some thing going
on and then the story was about that and
in almost every one of those situations
they were a stranger coming into the
situation other people didn't know them
that well and um and you didn't know
that much about them but then they had a
past that was revealed at some point you
never knew how true that past was or how
not true it was and you also didn't know
if they were a good guy or a bad guy for
most of the episode you had to find you
had to watch the entire episode to find
out are they the protagonist or are they
antagonist is Doug McClure going to end
up being his friend at the end and they
and they end the show Enza as a friend
or does that McClure end up killing him
at the end and that that literally is
the shows and I thought about well what
if I took about eight of those guys and
then trapped them in the room and there
is no Doug McClure there is no Michael
Landon as little joe in there there is
no moral Center there is no guy that you
know who's a good guy who you know who
he is that you can gravitate towards and
then the whole you know they trap them
in a room put a blizzard outside that's
almost like a monster
a monster movie waiting to devour them
if they ever step outside and then have
them uh what we'd find out who they were
through the hashing at about but you
couldn't trust anything anybody said and
then from that point on it was the the
idea of introducing the mystery element
which I had never done before that what
I was looking forward to yeah we had
done a script reading of the piece that
went really well and that script reading
and most of the actors of all the actors
are well most of the actors are here
we're in that and that script reading
and and I've to say we I think we walked
away from that script reading with a lot
of confidence about the material and I
finished a couple other drafts and then
we rehearsed it for a while and we had a
lot of confidence and I felt that I just
think I had a lot of confidence in the
material so I felt that if we get it at
a 99-seat theater off of Santa Monica
Boulevard it would be really good and if
we did it on the London stage it would
be really good so let's do it in seventy
millimeter and make it really really
good because I felt they would make it
would make it event it would make it
very very cinematic I could really shoot
the weather in a way that it would
literally be another character in a way
that I wouldn't be able to do on stage
per se also if I shoot it in seventy
millimeter well that's kind of expensive
so the studio is going to be is going to
make an attempt to actually get it shown
in seventy millimeter at least to some
degree or another and so I wouldn't just
be relying completely on digital
projection which I've worked a little
too long to just have diminishing
results
I don't think seventy millimeter was
created just to shoot the seven wonders
of the world and mountain ranges I
actually think that um there's an
intimacy to big scope formats like that
if you use it the correct way I have
shot a lot of close-ups of this man
right here
but I have never shot close-ups the way
they look in this movie with him you
know as you're beginning to make any
film you sit down and talk to the
director about what he or she wants to
do with Quentin that first couple
meetings have a greater importance
because he's essentially going to
outline to me how we're going to produce
the movie and how we're going to make
the movie and why he wants to do
everything that he wants to do and as a
producer your job is as it always is
with all directors is to support them
but with I think with Quentin he has an
instinctual way that he wants to make
the movie and our job is to just find
ways in which to support and hopefully
enhance that vision and do the wacky
things that he would like to do because
they're going to they're really good
ideas what we already decided this was a
really intimate ensemble piece after we
did the rehearsal in the reading and
when we started to rehearse in the
studio here in LA they built minis for
us to rehearse for like two and a half
three weeks and as we moved around that
room we realized what our relationships
were with each other who wanted to be
close to who wanted to be close to who
where the heat sources were how we
wanted to use them and the scope of that
lens we were told what it was so we
realized we were doing a play so even if
they're shooting on that side of the
room you can see what's going on over
here so we needed to have lives so we
found our business we found the things
we needed to do while the other actors
were working we found places where the
other actors could look over their
shoulders and see if we were looking or
paying attention to what they were doing
and not paying attention so it became a
very intimate exercise between all of us
and making sure we were supporting the
other actors on the other side of the
room no matter what was going on I want
to ask about this shot of Daisy it's for
how long a shot five minutes shot of
Daisy oh you mean though
she plays the guitar yes oh yeah yeah
we're ound that for four or five minutes
and I like that yeah I mean when we saw
it in 70 you don't want to cut away like
there's no there's no look at how
beautiful the image is and how much
detail you can see in every aspect of
the frame but but of course we did get
the opportunity to use some of the
coverage in the multiplex version of the
movie because you know it's not in 70
its digital so you'll be able to see
some of that I mean there's a different
editorial cut okay it's seeing the DCP
has a few different little moments that
just are a little different
all right because it's like well it's
not 70 it's not LA bohème at La Scala
it's you're going to the Tarzana nine
all right to watch it and maybe
everybody isn't so precious about the
whole damn thing just to just to sort of
clarify so the version that you all saw
this 70 millimeter with the overture and
the intermission is our movie that's
what we're presenting for two weeks plus
exclusively in 98 theaters throughout
North America the same thing will be
replicated in Europe and Asia etc later
and that's what how we're starting two
weeks plus and then on January 8th
everywhere is our multiplex version
which doesn't have the intermission the
overture in about five minutes take it
out that's that's the deal between the
two versions Quentin has such a wealth
of character information so you kind of
start there but from that you know we
really had these Western archetypes all
in one room so you have the sheriff and
the bounty hunter and the cowboy and so
really fleshing out those kiddos
archetypes to both fit and deceive their
characters and each other
was something that was really fun to do
we worked with a lot of film references
obviously and I also worked with the
Autry museum and we were able to use
some of their their pieces from the
1800s that we were able to look at and
like John Roose coat is a coat straight
from the Autry and it was like he's a
bully so I wanted him to be a bully on
screen to take over that space and you
know
Sam's costume is kind of like the
Lincoln letter it's disarming it's
debonair it's Lee Van Cleef so I think
that was sort of where we started and
obviously having such great actors to
work with is always a dream yeah I mean
it's amazing how much Courtney
was telling about Daisy and how much it
informed me actually actually when I
first went to meet on the movie was in
Quentin's guest house and there were her
boards were every character had a board
and on the board were drawings of the
characters and pictures from the period
and fabrics and furs and I just was so
inspired it was just such a cool room to
walk into and see all of this inspiring
beautiful research and the drawings and
and then to see the costumes the details
like my gloves you know there's a I
could feel the week she had had with
John Ruth by putting on the clothes
there's a hole in one of the fingers on
the glove the gloves are hand
embroidered everything she did whether
you saw it or not a lot you didn't see
there he was surprised how much you
couldn't see but ever didn't matter to
Courtney like everything whether you saw
it or not was going to be absolutely
perfect and so beautiful and so real and
it weighed a ton and it kept us it was
warm
yeah and that was her aim was to keep us
warm but to be completely authentic down
to like literally the soles of our shoes
how much back and forth is there between
you and Quentin about dialogue and about
character I don't know I've never never
really talked about that I just got a
phone call from Quentin he said I'm
going to do this reading you know you
would do the reading I said hey that'd
be fun and I didn't realize it was a
screenplay that had been leaked and it
had angered him and then I learned later
on that this was that screenplay and
then that I understood why he was angry
because he was only partially finished
with it he wasn't really anywhere near
done with it
and you know we started talking about
that and the next thing I knew we were
going to rehearse it I thought oh I
guess he wants to get this in shape to
show somebody and the next thing I knew
we were going to put this in front of
1600 people at a theater and I thought
well oh yes he wants to see this thing
so he ended up we ended up doing it and
in the process of that one day when we
were doing death Proof I was in the
middle of a scene and I was talking to
one of the actresses of playing the
playing the part during the role was say
in the words and I just got into one of
these takes where I was boring myself to
death and I just was boring myself so
much I just started doing it like John
Wayne they just like get going with
something and he didn't stop me most I
think you know and would have been most
other guys would have said whoa cut what
are we doing here
but he didn't do that he went in okay
now go back go half way back and go back
and do it do it all like John Wayne and
then I did that he said now stop and
stop and go here and I thought oh this
is so great that was alive again and
happening and having a great time and it
actually made sense for some of what
you'd written earlier and then when we
started this I kind of looked at him and
he was like looking at me like yeah go
there so for the reading I did then for
coming back to do the movie I didn't I
didn't want to do that but I didn't want
to you know I do it Quentin didn't want
to do so it's like we did I didn't
really talk about it but we just sort of
started there and fine it was kind of
interesting for me because I just sort
of did it until I figured he's going to
get he's going to change it's pretty
soon here and it's sure enough one day
he said okay let's that's good now let's
start let's start losing that and go
somewhere else
so it was just that it was also a
process with you know with Quentin of
trying to find something I got about six
names on the part of the script that I
have that some of it's Jackie Gleason
some of it's Broderick Crawford
you know some Jason Robards guys that in
certain kinds of ways and certain kinds
of movies that reminded me of a place
it's okay to go to in creating a
character and I just thought was
wonderful have the opportunity to you
know try to pile up another another
character that'd be fun to do I wrote
for Sam I wrote for Kurt you start kind
of falling in love with the one
character that you're not writing for an
actor because that character just kind
of goes wherever it goes and then you
write the whole story and then that's
where it goes and now I have to find
somebody to do it but you know the way
Daisy was written you know there's a
whole lot you know I could I could read
any of the guys and they have a lot of
dialogue to say and Daisy as she doesn't
have a lot of dialogue until he gets to
the end and and you can't really ask an
actress to come in and deliver like say
her big monologue that she gives at the
end in an office and oh wow that's it
because you have to have almost done the
entire movie and played that whole role
to get to that spot so um so I brought
the I brought Jennifer and she she did a
she did a really in we had a lot of fun
and she did really intriguing intriguing
work in it that I actually thought oh
this this could be good she could be
really interesting in that it was really
really intriguing but frankly it was
more about going back and having my own
Jennifer Jason Leigh Film Festival and
I've always been a big fan of hers and
it just doubly enamored me of her and it
made me realize just what a fantastic
actress she is and you know everybody in
Hollywood in the 90s felt that Jennifer
Jason Leigh was the female Sean Penn and
if I have this rogues gallery of men
that I have to deal with I need a female
Sean Penn I like to put in this thing
and so I did but we did have a actually
she almost says it better than I do we
had a nice discussion and I go um look
we're put this together but um we have
to you have to build Daisy we have you
have to live Daisy day by day by day so
let's just do it together let's go on
this journey together and let's just
let's not be result-oriented
let's not figure out about effects and
how we're going to solve them let's just
be Daisy everyday let everything happen
to you and let's just build
from there she might probably describe
it even better than I do but that was
the idea getting it off so the trip is
that was though because we watched her
throughout rehearsal and I mean we're
all you know quitting veteran so we do
what we do and Jennifer was kind of she
was walking on eggshells a little bit
you know but she's with this one who's
like constantly gonna car all right and
at a certain point it's like things
change in a very interesting way so
until we got in those clothes and we
started to shoot that first day and
we're in the snow out there and I'm
walking up on that stagecoach with my
hands up Jennifer's been kind of quiet
and tame all that time and I knew she
was dead with Kurt and she sticks her
head out the window and she's never done
that before I'm like what Quinn don't
let us improvise what the [ __ ] going
on but then I realized oh oh [ __ ] that's
Daisy she kind of she got a black eye
because I've never seen all that stuff
and she's got a costume on and
everything changes when you get dressed
and you're out there in it and she blew
that snot out of her nose and then she
started gnawing on the stagecoach window
I was standing there like Jennifer's
lost her mind and then I realized oh
[ __ ] this is the Daisy we've been
waiting to see and then I get in the
stagecoach and Kurt elbows are in the
face and she's sitting there looking at
me and I'm staring at her and we'd
rehearsed this and all of a sudden she
winked at me I went what the [ __ ] just
happened when the Quinn's right behind
me Quinlan did she wink at you you go
yeah [ __ ] she just waved can you
believe that [ __ ]
and that's when we knew okay we got
Daisy in the stagecoach and she's crazy
and she's feral and then we knew she was
going to be fine from that point on